hey everyone I have updates from the
Magnus trainer team and our I gave the
tactics frenzy we've made some
improvements the last week the most
notable is the ability now to retry your
puzzle so if you make a mistake for
instance like that you can now instead
of looking at the solution get the same
puzzle over again and try to find a
better move I'm gonna say that I should
have taken this one and then take this
one then that one and I'm gonna take it
with a queen coz that's so beautiful the
bishops giving Czech needs we've also
changed our rating algorithm so now if
you get the right answer you will not
lose rating regardless of how much time
you spend on a puzzle I do recommend
though that you don't get stuck use for
optimal improving I recommend spending
no more than four minutes on a puzzle at
that stage it's better just to check the
answer
learn from what you didn't figure out
and again do better next time
we also have added hundreds of new
puzzles so that you never have to make
the same puzzle more than once and I
want to show you how you can change the
piece set so there are different choices
here I'm gonna go with this marble one
and I'm gonna go with the wooden board
so these are the updates we have for you
please send us more feedback so that the
game gets even better and I hope to see
you again I'll see you around next week